Each of the three solutions here that we're looking for is the x-coordinate of
the proper line at the point where the y-coordinate is equal to 400. So, we're
looking for where each of these lines intersects the line y equals 400. For line
number one, this happens right here, at 30 gallons. Brand 2 and brand 3 actually
both intersect our lovely green line at the same point. So, all three of these
lines the orange, light blue, and the green, meet at whatever this point is. We
know that the y-coordinate is 400 and the x-coordinate is, if you look down at
the x-axis, 25. Taking into account how many gallons of solution each of these
brands can give us for $400, it looks like now, brand 1 is actually the best
deal. So, turns out that it's a bit trickier to choose which brand is the best
to go with then Grant might have thought earlier. As you can see from our graph,
the brand that's going to help him use his money most efficiently is going to be
different depending on how much money he wants to spend. No matter how much
money that Grant decided to spend on cleaning solution, this graph is definitely
going to come in handy to help him make the best choice.